this is where are the pronouns an end of
the wedge thing comes in okay so if we
don't use female language for men we're
if we call trans women men and we said
that man is going to win the cycling
race the women's cycling race everyone
go no but because that man is referred
to as a trans woman and then now a woman
in the press then people have to have
these conversations which are ludicrous
because if we just said men and women he
and she there's there's none of this
confusion we're all very clear about
what we're talking about Rachel Reece
MacKinnon cause without Rachel McKinnon
he's he's a man . you know when people
go why well the lungs the muscle fibers
they're no because he's a man I did its
we sort of get into these cul de sacs of
like you've used the instance and I
think India is the one that introduced
you to the the idea that that happens in
new troe this sort of mix-up of whatever
it is hormones on hormone wash the
something Keith said it was absolute
nonsense but that's because we are
trying to explain things that are so
nonsensical and then we're trying to put
sort of intelligent hats on and explain
why it's true why it's not true if
they're just men that's it there's no
compromise suppose he's a no middle
ground where we can say okay fine
they're not women let's say what they
are is trans women and we create a
separate category so that those people
can get the comfort that they need they
can have their own pronouns used but for
the purposes of let's say spore and
other fields they're not treated exactly
as women in in that sense but broadly
speaking we give them to comfort the day
they need to feel good about themselves
so in order to compromise I will have to
change my language to something that I
know isn't true but I'm not saying you
have to say they're a woman I'm saying
you have to say that a trans woman for
example it's a new category let's say no
why I just don't I think it's it's
really bloody offensive
to think that you can just stick on some
clothes and and demand that I change the
way I'd think because I don't think that
I transwomen is a nonsense term woman it
doesn't apply to those but you don't
think there's a difference between me
and me having cut off my penis and
replaced it with an artificial vagina
and artificial breasts is that not a
different person and a different type of
person you've probably had troubled
human if you do that but I don't think
that makes you a different category of
human no and what a lot of women inputs
in particular women that I know very
close to me get in sensing enraged by
the term sis sis woman why is that so
contentious amongst women because it's
women after change all our bloody
language we're uterus have us I think in
Ireland now you're pregnant people Jesus
Christ it's I'm a woman it that should
be enough right but it's not enough
anymore because we have trans women and
so now apparently we have to have a
prefix this is why all the little tiny
kind of placating language right that
all the things that are supposed to be
nice and polite and kind why they're so
[ __ ] dangerous
because it means trans women and I think
the Green Party called us non trans
called
women I mean non trans women have been
[ __ ] off it's no
[Music]